my name is herb Johnson I would like to
ask who you talk about brain classical
music to the big audience but that is
like under the ER is doing so but Phil
then you always be a conflict like you
you are looking for the highest standard
and to bring the highest standard to the
big audience for me there will be
obviously conflict not necess I mean
highest standard I would not think that
the mission is to instantly find a big
audience for the B minor mass or
something or but but I first of all I
think that statistically there's many
many more people who are educated enough
to appreciate a hand handle opera for
example which is beautiful music there's
the tekapo Aria the nice melodies come
back if it's a nice production it can be
highly entertaining
so people who enjoy going to a musical
for example could enjoy a Handel opera
and would probably even hopefully
realize that there's even some added
value to this kind of music making and
in general I think it's opening up the
music scene in a sense that people who
are afraid of coming to a concert hall
shouldn't be afraid and the question is
well my idea is to probably play the
music in different places for example
that I the place itself stands for
something else if I do classical music
in a place that normally is used for
techno it's a first of all it's a
surprise for the audience to hear
something new and it will attract a
completely different audience and I know
that there's no not nobody has yet
invented the remedy for the slowly dying
classical music scene and the sales
figures for example for cities are about
half of what they have been ten years
ago it's a little secret I'm like I can
I can express tonight there's afternoon
so nobody has yet invented the remedy
but I think we need to do something and
we need to be
about it and the concert ritual as a me
putting on the dark suit walking out I
bow I sing then there's an applause I
bow and I go back that's in itself
probably not sufficient enough if if we
look at films
if I buy DVD I have the bonus features I
have added value I have the director and
the actors talking about what they like
about it what happened and I think we
live in a generation that appreciates
the background knowledge and the
audience is probably also interested in
hearing from the artist how he sees his
work or how why he likes a specific
piece and I experienced that the
listening explicit in quality is a
different one after I started talking in
a concert so just the the the change of
a music concert that after the first two
or three songs the singer says ladies
and gentlemen welcome the next three
songs I heard them first sung by Alfred
eller and I was so moved because of this
and that and then I sing it creates a
complete different tension in the hall
so first of all people hurt my speaking
voice or anybody who has still confusion
about why does he sing so high yeah
no that's that's that's one aspect
because otherwise I will not listen to
the music if the whole concert I wanna
but isn't it strange that he sings so
high so I solved I solved that problem
and I have a few more people who who
really listen to the music and I think
that in itself already is a simple thing
that musicians explain themselves a
little bit and it will enhance the
listening experience for the listener if
you like or conductor we have these
concerts where the conductor points the
attention to certain aspects of a
composition who told me recently there's
a concert series played twice whether
where every piece is played twice in a
concert first they play the piece and
then the musicians talk about it and
then they play it again and of course
once you've heard musicians talk about
it you listen to it completely
differently and it enhances the
listening pleasure so that's one thing
that could happen more often I think
thank you
my name is Jasper Lee start the question
I would like to ask you we know that in
classical philosophy especially in
classical ethics when we think of Plato
for instance Beauty truth and the good
are related it's not possible to
conceive of one of the terms without the
others so the question I would like to
put to you is whether to play music or
to listen to music will make one a
better person I said where is the goo
it's a very very good question I think
that that's why I included even Andrew
Lloyd Webber and under EU in in in
everything that happens in concerts it's
the the the soul changing aspect that
for example in bass music bar composed
music to save souls the mission was
clear it was meant to make us think to
repent to be better human beings and the
collective experience the ritual of the
concert is of course on different levels
a mind or emotion changing thing
so if period and on the simplest level I
could say the audience that leaves a
concert hall is an audience that is
different than the one that entered if
on a Friday afternoon concert I rush
into the hall I'm stressed I just made
it and then I listen to beautiful music
and I came by taxi and I told the driver
come on hurry up I have to the taxi
driver experiences a stressed person and
then I enter the taxi to go back home
and the taxi driver will say wow I had
lots of nice customers tonight they came
from a concert and the next day you go
to your workspace and you say well
yesterday I listened to BA all the
Rolling Stones or whatever so there is
the owner honest on a simple level there
ISM music can make us happy and whenever
I imagine it almost like a neuron neural
and a network that the planet is if you
imagine the earth completely black and
wherever a concert is over people leave
the hall it's always like a little flash
light that radiates out and and so
constantly there's enough bad things
happening constantly there's a positive
input into this world through the music
or art exhibitions or a film and I
strongly believe that this is what music
can do and the easiest level is it
entertains us and distracts us from our
problems the next step would be that
doing this doing a BA
massive passion or something I'm really
moved to tears for example and I learned
that I can can open up through music and
I or I gather new ideas about my life
and ideally that's what what art and
music can do and and even in a Handel
opera the libretti that have been
written in the 18th century have
universal truths about human beings
making difficult choices realizing that
there's no right or wrong choice
but one with probably less troubles or
more troubles and so I think every
concert is a cell that spreads out into
society and yes I believe that it's a
mission and it should ideally change us
into better human beings my name is
Brent hi when I think about beauty and
truth in music the music that comes most
to mind to me is things like the out of
the fugue by Bach or this sort of
so-called context-free music without a
very specific human context linked
toward or absolute music or you could
talk about you know the fugues of
Mendelssohn or anyone but as a singer I
guess using words most of the time if
not all the time which which transmit a
very specific semantic message all the
time and so most of the talk that's been
going on today has been about the truth
of that message so I would like to ask
that as a singer do you engage at all
with this kind of absolute context-free
music and if you do how do you do that
in a way it needs to
even instrumental music and I don't envy
instrumentalists because they don't have
the words and they have to come up with
what they have to make choices but I
think even the art of the fugue the
chamber list or pianist needs to extract
something needs to come to conclusion of
how could bar have meant it and funnily
enough the the the formal criteria of a
composition so here something starts
here it's developed here it comes back
again and there's a end that so we
understand sometimes the composition
comes to an end we hear something and a
certain formula in the music over a
certain amount of time suggests to us
okay soon it's going to end and to me
and I think that's with bar I'm I'm
pretty sure it also relates back to the
rhetorical aspect so I can pretend that
there's a I invent
a meaning of a phrase not not a specific
message but I can say this is urgent
the first movement it moves forward and
here it's calm and here I don't have any
ambition anymore you can play also with
the impulse to extract something or as
an instrumentalist and you could say I
play as if I'm alone on stage I'm
completely with my music so these are
the the choices that you make and it's
it's far more difficult but of course
when I when you have an opening movement
of a bar cantata and I conducted a while
ago in England the maracas Orchestra and
then I have instrumental music and I
have to find a vocabulary to talk to the
musicians to say how do we mean it
because piano is not piano piano stands
for timid pianos they can mean tender
piano can mean lovingly or whatever so
the the dynamic indications like
ornaments in music are just empty
formulas but if I want to communicate in
emotion in instrumental music I think
I'd first need to be aware of what
emotion I want to transmit find the
tools on my instrument and then the
third step again hope that my message
makes it to the audience here hi my name
is Liana de rooy and I was wondering
have you ever found a tendency towards
the cliche in yourself and if yes how
was the struggle sure sure
no no I the cliche in itself on
something that we all work with of
course it's it's an idea and it comes
from somewhere so even the cliche has a
root and usually the root is a nothing
evil but somebody's idea but
if I listen for example to a CD that I
recorded many years ago the Vivaldi
stubborn Mata with Caliban Keaney and
then there's this cantata chess at or my
chess otta
and I fine listen to it today I say yeah
that's how you felt at that time but
it's mainly beautifully sung even even
even if the shepherd complains about how
cruel don't realize it's so beautiful
how cruel she is so so yes and I at the
time of course I it's it's tempting to
just say okay I create a create a
beautiful sound and as I said there are
singers one of my students who was
always badly prepared and it was mainly
sight-reading lessons and it was
terrible but when she knew a piece and
she sang it it just she opened her mouth
and the audience was in tears so
although she never contemplated about
what she wants to sing yeah so there are
these discrepancies and it's what I've
always called a third step of the
musical communication so the cliche is
there and maybe even at days when when
or in a television show for example yeah
it's it's you sing in a TV show and you
know well this is what the people expect
it's the classic music so it needs to
look like classical music and then you
narrow your view you come you behave in
a in a different way but I think it
creates so much happiness to get rid of
the cliches that that there's other than
experimenting with it or yet trying how
does how does somebody feel you who
those things like this and and you make
a joke about it but other than that I
I'm not so tempted to to fall back the
only thing is that you could fall into
the imitation of yourself that you have
a certain way of singing and you repeat
yourself in a certain way here only yes
on behalf of all of us thank you so much
you